you were just at Bonnaroo I was yeah I  can't imagine with the with the level of  excitement that you generate how do you  go to Bonnaroo which is thousands and  thousand thousands of young people all  packed into a relatively I've been there  relatively small area how do you walk  around and just be like a normal person  without getting your clothes shredded  well there's two ways okay one is you  dress like a Mexican drug cartel which  is bandana sunglasses and hat you feel  really creepy but they don't recognize  you okay or two you just walk around  your face out in the open and they're  all so far gone on substances there's  like throw a Twinkie and they like go  running after anyways what's your sin  wiki stick works every time every time  it's gonna be work very nicely free so  you had a good time you know I was  relaxed and enjoy yourself